what's going on reject nation Greg outta
here John humph we are going to watch
the trailer trailer we missed out on the
premiere during Comic Con cutthroat City
the sequel to cutthroat island I'm so
excited for it guys it's directed by RZA
yeah from the wu-tang clan and stars a
bunch of actors in here this request
comes from the patron video request for
war tear whatever video request I must
definitely do from JD Jason Dolan my man
how you doing Jason Olin recently
visited from Atlanta he's a really good
friend of ours actually we've hung out
with him a few times and he's our friend
who's one of our highest pledges
inspiration also an inspiration we just
asked him for advice on so many things
and and why it's him donating to our
yeah hardcore film buff a wonderful
screenwriter and he actually has a movie
he's working on right now that he's
probably gonna be directing and I read
this before it's great it's a vampire
thriller it was awesome script seriously
him real anything about it but they got
a lot of big things in motion for that
so so at the end of the script what
happened - he has played a major impact
in my life outs of late - with getting
back into writing and rediscovering my
roots of why I even started youtube and
all that so Jason I want to give you a
sincere shout-out saying when I'm really
famous I'm gonna get you so much bad
there I can't say it oh because you know
the times we live in
yeah so so much valuable fish I know
from industry from watch the cuss about
city
oh yeah
[Music]
don't dig up a we use underwater before
Katrina they rebuild notice what about
us
Dean was a goddamn joke this happens
just how they want one Tiger educate
black may know that man nah cuz I'm
still in the night what we're gonna do
here no cops
we all need the money we ain't no
gangsters could be our only option
that's not a good idea
Trina means purification
[Music]
Wesley Snipes
[Music]
like a copper so okay
cut the road city I'm not fully familiar
with Riza's work but I always associate
him as some like action movie director
like well didn't he make like man with
the iron fists or whatever yeah and
directed an episode of iron fist always
associated him is like that so that's
what I'm expecting I'm like her Wesley
Snipes no looting has that Shaolin
connection yeah yeah but this looks like
a gritty ass drama yes this is an
interesting concept I don't know if this
is a true story at all it kind of feels
like it could be yeah definitely spired
by which is effective for a film that's
a compliment if it's not a story I mean
it definitely seems like it's based on
real life the dire circumstance and and
desperate measures the Katrina thing was
all fake though yeah it's all just a
consult egi is I think it was fine they
just put that on the news yet just
wanted attention because they're trying
to strive from all the Mardi Gras yeah
exactly
it was terrible actually that I believe
the effects are still being I mean I
felt I liked the concept of it it's
fascinating to me cuz you think for a
second like I we're gonna watch a movie
about people struggling during Hurricane
Katrina yeah and then instead you get a
movie about these lower-class citizens
in the black community who take
advantage of Katrina to pull off these
heist which I find to be kind of a neat
backdrop or a heist movie actually well
it's also the push to because it's like
circumstances I get the sense we're
already not great at many things I'm
still in the night one now then you have
this natural disaster adding on top of
that and yeah things all that much worse
and it's not being handled well no no
and so yeah like I can see why both the
excuse of having the leeway that the
storm allows you but also just the angst
and yeah pushed to the limits you know
they would cause I'm going to just go
out and be like you know what we just
got to get ours I think this film has a
lot of potential to be something with
more depth and meaning than a typical
heist thriller because I was really
pulled into before the high
I didn't know this was a heist movie so
before any that high stuff started
happening I was like oh this is an
interesting tale to see during the
Hurricane Katrina times I just hope that
it's backdrop and the time that set in
still plays a major effect and lets that
theme really resonate throughout as
opposed to all right now that we got the
high stuff going let's just make it a
heist movie yeah I mean at least judging
by this trailer the desperation and the
intensity definitely emanates off of it
so it gives me faith that this movie
will probably would be intense rather
than flip the switch and just become
cool no I don't think it'll be that like
American animals like plotting out the
highs where it's all smooth and cool and
stuff I'm interested in the ensemble too
I mean this looks like it could be the
perfect combination of an intense heist
thriller with a pretty relevant social
drama as well yeah and I feel like
that's a great idea for right now you
know especially yeah this looks really
cool I'm glad we caught it thank you
guys for recommending thank you Jason
Dolan for recommending him yeah well
what do you guys think would you pull
off a heist
during a hurricane I believe there's a
movie about that oh yeah subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bow because subscribers are
broken and check us out on patreon where
we got full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A music video coverage would
love to have you become a patron eject
to do